first off congratulations the movie is
exceptional thank you ran I'll come your
way first and I'll preface this question
by saying that the book is also
exceptional but is there anything about
seeing the story unfold on screen that
Amplified something for you made a
concept or a scene more powerful than
you ever realized it could be yeah
that's a great question the the what I
was writing I think in pursuit of was a
feeling of unsteady
and that the the idea that the story is
sort of Shifting under the feet of the
reader constantly and it was such an
interesting experience to watch Sam's
movie and experience that as an as a as
a viewer and I know this story inside
and out it is from my head and I was
still able to access that and so I think
it reminded me I've heard um Sam talk a
lot about uh tone is the word you use
when you talk about this and it was
really it's been interesting for me to
think about tone to think about that
particular noun and how how I'm going to
apply that in the work I'm doing going
forward because I just finished a book
and I usually I I think of it maybe as
mood or atmosphere but these are all
sort of synonyms for the same thing that
if you I think what you've said is that
if you get that right then everything
else falls into place and I think that's
really an accurate and interesting
Insight artistically I'm very much
looking forward to checking out that
next book now um Sam for you in the
adaptation I was curious did you ever
think about doing any cutaways to other
people Beyond these two families I just
kept thinking about One Moment In the
book in particular it's when they're
doing laundry and they mention the the
laundry facility that they go to and
what happens to the person that runs it
so did you ever consider adding
something like that to the film no
because again I think when when you
think about something that works so well
in a literary medium I felt for me once
you do that in a sort of a cinematic
approach you break some sort of spell
when you break POV like that and just to
kind of piggy back on tone I remember
the feeling that I wanted was this sort
of Dre that this movie kind of starts
off like a dream and it turns into a
nightmare I mean that's like a very sort
of visceral feeling that I've
experienced and I I I I wanted to really
um uh really channel that and I think
the way to do that is to stick with
these people and to not ever escape the
borders of their world um there's
claustrophobia in there but there's also
this kind of like you said this sand
shifting underneath their feet um you
just don't quite know what's outside of
those kind of four corners of their
world and um I think that just added to
this sort of nightmarish quality to the
film that I think would you would have
lost if you cut away to other people
have a feeling you're spot on with that
um I'm going to end with what is
essentially the the million-dollar
question with a story like this Sam I'll
toss it to you but Raman you can chime
in if you want as well because this does
pertain to the book too what is it like
preserving mystery and challenging
viewers to engage but while also making
sure that the story is satisfying and
offering enough you know what I will say
this is this look going into it and
reading the book and knowing how the
book kind of beautifully handles
ambiguity in the end I remember as an as
sort of a reader and then as a you know
and thinking about the movie I love
movies where the end of the film is the
beginning of a
conversation um and when you answer all
these questions it closes the door on
that and for me that robs the audience
of something I want I want my favorite
movie going experiences is leaving the
theater and going to a coffee shop and
arguing with my friends for two hours
about what it all meant hearing other
people's interpretations and um and I
also just think that's that is sort of
reflective of life we Face ambiguities
all the time and um sure it can be
frustrating sure it could even feel
unsatisfying but um there's something
really authentic and true to life about
it that you can't you can't take that
away from and I really wanted to commit
to that and again it was it was sort of
your book's ending that really made me
inspired to kind of keep that in the
film that's kind of you I I I love that
the film retains that I think it is a
gesture of respect to the audience I
think that people I think that there's a
lot of cultural forms that maybe
um without meaning to talk down to an
audience a little bit and I think
audiences can handle stuff that is
difficult that is a question mark and I
think the adaptation so really
beautifully walks that line where I I I
I know the movie I know the book of
course but I'm sitting there having the
sort of thrilling experience as a viewer
and then I turned to my husband after we
saw the first screening and I was like
we we have to discuss this like what a
great feeling what a great feeling when
a work of art can can provide that the
best feeling and the best feeling with
an adaptation where you get two versions
of the same story that wind up enhancing
the other I feel like that's the best
scenario with a book to film adaptation
congratulations thank you thank you so
much